[Musik]
es war einmal ein schloss und viele
wilde gerüchte
in 800 jahren hat sich hier allerlei
spuk angesammelt hexen geister und seit
ein paar jahren noch ein devote
schlossherr das ist nicht transsilvanien
dass es graubünden
[Musik]
das ist die geschichte über einen der
von sich selbst sagt er habe nicht alle
tassen im schrank
er sei gar nicht interessant sagt mit
der schlosser interessant seien bloß die
gerüchte also das im wesentlichen das
ehrt mich ja erforscht das zeigt
eigentlich dass ich wieder so herzlich
im endspiel und nicht wo es wie massa
als auch nigeria kleber nicht und sucht
das als kompliment
ich wohne in der nachbarschaft und sich
das gerücht der herr papa hat ihm das
schloss gekauft
[Musik]
wie schräg ist elisa schlossherr
diesjährig thoma seit zehn jahren drohen
der 48-jährige auftrag stein bei mars
sein allein nur mit einer haushälterin
zusammen bewohnter tag stein mit seinen
acht siegerinnen anja ist schloss
fräulein und schlossgeist kirchen und
hexe sie kennt sich aus in dämonischen
dingen
sie möchte mit jährlich eine hypnotische
rückführung zu den geistern und hexen
machen dass sich weniger mit geister
oder hexen zu tun sondern einfach ob er
wirklich den mittelalter schon mal
gelebt hat ob eine verbindung hat zu zu
schlössern irgendwann irgendwas muss da
sein sonst hat jemand nicht so sondern
extrem hand zu halten beuern und
mittelalterlichen geschichten und wurden
und bin der meinung da ist mehr
anja zieht das schicksal an
eine getötete tochter ein verstorbener
ehemann ein abgebranntes haus und seit
sie hier ist das getuschel beim nachbarn
es ging hier die wildesten gerüchte dass
er ich hier im freudenhaus hat und
welche skandalöser wir hätten die hunde
darauf die leute sagen gilt immer gern
dabei kommen die ja nicht mal
herausgegeben in denen man in einem
spaziert ja ich bin natürlich die
früchte köchin ist ganz klar
die blöd nur dass er vorher niemand
gefunden hat der schloss heute bzw
nicht in der lage war mehr ich hier zu
leben und den haushalt zu führen und
alles ich glaube dass manchmal einige
ein bisschen einfacher sich die sind
schon vier jahre hier bin
auf dieses jüngste gerücht für die köche
wie das jüngste gericht hat chrysler
händler als chrysler musik poesie heißt
es wiederum dass also der liepold alle
herab und somit finger auf mich zeigen
und das muss jemand mal eine ehre für
mich zuhause vertrieben
das 10 energie ich bin nie wohl aber
dass ich dir wo es nicht versucht serie
nicht offiziell als linker nicht hinter
diesem tor beginnt der freistaat
germanien ein paar spinner in
deutschland hatten einen start germanien
ausgerufen
die fantasten sucht nehrig thoma als
schweizer botschaft heraus wo der
schlossherr diplomat und machte aus
parkstein ein germanisches fürstentum
mit gutem grund dem vernehmen nach auf
der kanzlei höre ich nämlich dass sich
thoma dann auf den standpunkt stellte
der gemeinde keine steuern mehr bezahlen
zu müssen
schloss dachstein ist erich strutz pool
auch um den wert ranken sich gerüchte
dass rolls royce mit dem geld klar aber
ist das lebenswerk und was daheim an
wunderschönen alten stall nach
bauzeichner lehre und der handelsschule
versuchte sich ehrlich auch als landwirt
die ersten jahre hielt er auf dem
schloss kühe und geissen fantastisch
geht rechts großer piz beverin das teil
ganz schön auf trab gehalten
durch diesen herren vom schluss oben das
erste was ich über ihn hörte war dass er
zwar einer der reichsten im tal sei aber
ganz arm auf die welt gekommen sei und
eigentlich sei der herr ein bauernhof
ursprünglichen große aufgesucht und ein
kollege von mir hat dann ihre marke
sagte heckel zwar sonnhof aber schlag
auf das schloss rufen nicht dass er
schon ich habe überhaupt gemessen was an
ist aber mittel -und zwar seine niedrige
mieten und das habe ich dann halt einmal
müsse der halle 22 sekunden aber
stadtschlosses nicht
als schlossherr züchtete erich segal
inzucht dezimierte aber den bestand das
ist der diener der stift grund stiefels
gaisburg auf dachstein geboren ist und
wie alt also für uns erste tier
überhaupt kann der haben wir gerade
wisse wie das ist einfach kann das ist
nämlich der urknall simuliert oder sie
aber ganz und dominante facebook sie und
der hochintelligente sie also den
intelligent wie einen hund kann das
weniger also was denn alles verstanden
da habe ich also alles richtig
das arbeitslicht wir haben natürlich
retro mannschaft flügel spielt eine
moderne schaffen
damit habe ich geschrieben
da wird abgelegt aber jetzt wäre für
technik kontrolliert da wir bruder wir
gemacht da wir tun was ist social
vertragsteil der seminare computerhacker
das sammel alter computer ist eine
wirklich große leidenschaft der
bauzeichner versteht sich als architekt
mit arabischen freundin träumte er ich
von einer wüsten eisenbahn der baulinien
ist eingeschlafen heute hat es weder
türen noch ziegen auf dem schloss der
ruf ist verpachtet
es scheint mir ich weiß nicht so recht
was er soll mit seinem leben
geld hat er ja genug ausdauer das ist
bibliothek
der 48 jährige schloss er ist ein riese
von einem menschen
und wie in jedem großen mann steckt auch
in erich ein kleiner bub der aus dem
koloss ausbrechen um die die arme
genommen werden will
die software kommt mit vier epiney
adoptiert wurde und ihre familie wurden
nochmals der brief klärt jetzt schon
erwähnt und hielt auf der steig ich habe
da meine eltern oft es diesbezüglich
gefragt und ich weiß gar nicht was die
ersten vier jahre mit mir passiert ist
das war es kein mensch dass er nie einen
unser gefunden
der hat mir angst gemacht da haben meine
mutter stelle gemacht
ich habe früher am abend als ich so
lange her im internet die jungs ich bin
aktuell ten und 104 jahre verstrichen
sämtliche guten weg sind nach ein wenig
leben immer noch hinter hein landet
nicht und die tägliche wie sehr
liebenswerter grunde nicht und darum
interessiert es mich nicht interessiert
das nicht hatte vorstellen
ich habe gedacht wenn wir zu dem ort
spezielle schnitt sie eigentlich wollte
ich dem nicht ganz alltäglich lebenslauf
von erich etwas näher kommen
aber es gelingt mir nicht mit ihm über
seine seelischen verletzungen zu
sprechen
sein trikot ist die näher als jede
menschenseele vor vier jahren suchte er
ich wieder mal eine frau gefunden hat er
eine haushälterin anja kann zur probe
schlossherr bietet oslos und ein
großzügiges salär anja bleibt seit vier
jahren wohnt sie eine treppe über l
beide betonen wie in einer ehe ohne
trauschein aber auch ohne 6 das sieht
auch noch gut dass man auch mal saniert
wir sind jetzt da die holländischen
vorgänger haben billigen massentourismus
betrieben darunter hat das schloss
gelitten
seit zehn jahren ist erich am
restaurieren
er möchte die mittelalterliche burg in
ein nobles balle verwandeln
diese leidenschaft kennt im tal kam eine
und schon schießen wieder gerüchte aus
dem boden im geiste sind im anzug ein
respektabler sind es plötzlich tanja
deiner mal premier wieder arg und
bestimmen
sie hatte vergessen sie aber bestimmen
also gar nicht was da los ist
und sind sie plötzlich sonntags hat sich
damit aber und die schwerter und theke
lothar steiger hus sind die handlung und
wo man dabei klaffen sind da steige
musst du haben sich natürlich die regel
auf horizontalen gestellt und zwar auf
die elite der ist nicht so gekommen ist
dann einfach auch sie nicht und wir
sehen also eine tgkk gar nicht so horner
das geht gar nicht denn physikalische
dass er geradezu erleichtert
begeistert sind sind hexen nicht weit
die letzte hexe des bündnerland wurde
nicht weit von hier hingerichtet das
schloss dachstein diente als kulisse für
einen spielfilm über die grausige tat im
internet habe ich den streifen gefunden
dieser hexen will bis vor sechs jahren
gedreht wurde nicht oma hat sein schloss
zur verfügung gestellt dafür kam beinahe
er auf den scheiterhaufen die bündner
polizei bekam diesen film in die finger
und raubte der sache folterszenen zum
realen alltag geschlossen gehörten
sie verhafteten erich wie sich
herausstellte dass alles nur ein spiel
war also nur dummes gerede dass es sich
dabei um einen satten film handelt von
dem aus es muss das ist richtig und
vereinte der russische ist und auch von
der szene
ich kenne eigentlich wo wir sind
mich stört das nicht ab und zu und finde
ich das sowieso stück wo er auftaucht
sind die gerüchte nicht weitmar ist
weniger maries mehr an diesem gewohnt
dass das schloss ein freudenhaus sei ist
tatsächlich nur leeres gerücht in lack
und leder oder schmiedeeisen im schloss
hat man sich schon sei die erotischen
spielereien hingegeben
das soll anja seien die haushälterin auf
dem schloss war ursprünglich designerin
entwarf möbel zum essen und zum spielen
ein bett getarnt als zusammenklappbar
tisch
anjas website ist in der szene ein
begriff
anfangs jahr hat er ich zu einem großen
fest geladen auf seine eltern kommen zu
besuch
ich befinde mich rum vom 11 denkt man
hat ihn jetzt aber nur sehr schmal wo
ich sehe schon mit ihm kopien ich
gestorben
da oben ein paar kratzer und hat der
subaru vergleich geschlossen spinnstube
sondern lade tragen zwar recht
arrangeurin großen schritt als vater dem
sohn mit frauen zusammen und gibt
vertrauen und defizite waren auch die
flammen sind also kurz nach dem spiel
wieder mal bremsen
heute liegt der reguläre skonto
und jetzt die traumprinzessin der
schlossherr hat eine zürcher brauerei
geholfen
dort war sein großvater seelig direktor
sein großes glück waren die
adoptiveltern das reiche kinderlose paar
hat das waisenkind tief ins herz
geschlossen
trotzdem ich vermute die ersten
lebensjahre haben narben hinterlassen
[Gelächter]
will nicht und kann nicht und kann es
150 gäste wurden erwartet viele waren
verhindert so sultan abdul rachman der
medien bahnhof in arabien bauen will
fürst von und zu liechtenstein leider
auch baronin von bredow die mit dem
fürsten titel sie alle kennt der aus
adeligen deutschen kreisen
anja die haushälterin in der rolle als
fürstin
es ist 15 unter null der riesenkröte
gehört er dem herrn die kleine da können
[Musik]
bei diesen temperaturen lernen gäste und
personal was es heißt zufrieden wie ein
schlosshund
für die festgemeinde gibt es
kartoffelsalat und kaltes freibier erich
hat seinen getreuen einen einmaligen
höhepunkt versprochen
er habe keine kosten gescheut ein
riesenspektakel vom stapel zu lassen
eine show im schlossgarten von tag
steigen
register wer schon ein wenig diese
schloss sein
[Musik]
das war's denn am tag danach der
schlossherr ist wieder alleine könig die
letzten gäste sind gegangen alltag
breitet sich aus erich hat nicht mehr
freunde wie vor dem fest
essen
das ist der große spießer erichs ehefrau
ist ausgeflogen
sie ist pilotin und cac vor fünf jahren
von thomas scheiden lassen
seither ist er ich allein allein in dem
siebenstöckigen schloss mit seinen drei
speisesälen ja damals schon 140 sitzen
immer da
da inoffizielle platz und weil ihre
freundin hätte oder frau hätte wird auf
der a3 siebter der hinterstraße wird an
ihre kür
da seit ihrem jahr das tradition so ende
diese geschichte nicht ganz wie merken
aber trotzdem wenn sie nicht gestorben
sind so leben sie noch heute
[Musik]
er ich hätte es ganz gerne er würde eine
frau finden die ihm zeigt wo es langgeht
[Musik]
wasser das gerücht devote schloss herzog
dominante prinzessin fesselt ihn ganz
[Musik]